what do you do oh yeah what I do yeah
yeah okay take a six
hi We're Keith and Emily from Bernie
Texas and I'm an auction manager for a
major real car company and I am a
stay-at-home homeschooling mom to our
two beautiful little girls I do some
stuff on the side but my primary duty is
to teach our girls and do dishes well I
had really no real financial training
for my parents and so we started
marriage with no clue yeah we did
everything like we couldn't do anything
halfway we could just have any apartment
we had to have a downtown loft apartment
we could just have any car we had to
have a convertible a brand-new
convertible everything is just like dave
says they need everything that took our
parents 30 years to achieve we wanted it
right away right then yeah and so this
downward spiral just began but we
couldn't really see what was happening
we were blinded by it I think we had no
idea the mess that we were getting
ourselves into yeah what kind of debt
was the 162 credit cards medical debt a
couple of car loans and student loans
yes my to student loans Wow if I didn't
hear that things were bad for him then I
assumed everything was okay I mean while
I'm freaking out me yeah IVA
I have a husband who's who's scared you
know I was a new mom and I wanted to go
do stuff with my new baby and I remember
um like searching through our junk
drawer for change just because I wanted
to just go get a snack
and take my screaming child out for a
ride in the car to calm her and I
couldn't find any change just to go get
a drink from the corner store and by
this time we were in our first home
which we built from the ground up but we
were completely house completely house
poor yep everybody the house had a baby
that's what's expected so we were just
doing what was normal we had an issue
with property tax that they came in that
we weren't expecting we thought it was
escrow and I'm completely blindsided us
we got it in the mail I I opened it up I
was like what is this it was for like
almost $4,000 ridiculous yeah and we
literally like put it aside and a stack
of junk mail like it would just they
would just go away like that's how in
denial we were of what was going on I
think that was about the time that we
saw the ad for financial peace
[Music]
we were sitting in church and we were
just thumbing through the monthly
newsletter and there was a little blurb
in there about Financial Peace
University yeah let's try it
it wasn't a gun how thing but yeah we
probably need to do that that'll help us
give us a few tips not knowing that we
were walking into a complete 180 we went
to the first class and yeah it wrecked
me I mean it was just like we woke up we
never looked back like it was just we
were on fire right away we were on fire
there is a plan there's the structure
and this works for people we can do this
this is it like this is this is where it
starts right here it was the decision
that needs to be made and it was just
the beginning of our incredible journey
so from there we started working the
baby stuffs we started getting pretty
crazy and people thought they just did
not get it
we were we were on track we we were
we've realized we weren't the Joneses we
were trying to keep up with everybody
else we had completely flipped our
mentality that we we need to maybe even
downsize and and try to sell this house
and so we we met with our agent real
estate agent again so we know where we
were going and we listed the house and
it sold in six days we found an
apartment on the third floor so we had
two girls a chocolate lab puppy on the
third floor apartment
I mean all the equity we made on the
house we put towards debt oh that was
depressing but it was just another life
this is what we did and we gotta clean
it up now
[Applause]
I mean there were many times when I was
just brought to my knees when we sold
our house I was the last one out and I
remember crumbling to the floor just in
tears because I had no idea what God had
in store for us so over this seven years
and I would just ask Heath what is the
point of this I would get depressed he
would get depressed and we kind of just
had to lean on each other like we're
gonna get this done we just kept
thinking what's in our future what what
do we want our house to look like what
kind of life to want to give our girls
how do we want to do I think gosh that
that sense of freedom is like nothing
else you've ever experienced I've had
sleepless nights with the debt and the
payments and everything else we got
there the mess we gotten into as someone
who's just beginning it's hard to
imagine what it feels like because
you've struggled with debt for so long
it's a reality for ya it's just it's
been your reality I mean to be on the
other side after so long like it's just
it's incredible
when Keith woke me up he was like I'm
about to hit Send on this to you do you
want to see this happen I was like I've
bounced out of bed he clips in
[Music]
this weight was off of our shoulders and
it was that freedom that I have not
tasted so we paid off one hundred and
sixty two thousand in seven years and
the hard work and persistence all the
tears all of the frustration all of the
anger is so worth it because now there's
just peace and freedom freedom
[Music]